good evening from Pretoria after day two
of the Oscar Pistorius murder trial a
day that has proved emotional for the
witnesses and for the accused and a day
of controversy at one stage historias
himself was seen wiping a tear from his
eyes as he listened to evidence of the
night that he shot dead his girlfriend
reeva Steenkamp and one of his
neighbor's
Michelle Berger at one point broke down
in court as she recalled hearing a woman
screams on the night of the shooting
little earlier the judge had interrupted
proceedings to reprimand the media after
discovering a local newspaper and a
local news channel had shown pictures of
miss Berger against her wishes
Paul Harrison's report contains some
flash photography running the courtroom
gauntlet Oscar Pistorius alongside his
brother Karl sheltering from the rain
protected from the cameras but while it
is the athlete on trial for murder
barely before his defense lawyer Barry
Roux could resume his cross-examination
of state witnesses the South African
media found itself in the dock you did
not believe Oscar Pistorius version as
witness
Michelle Berger continued her testimony
through an intervention from prosecutor
Gerry nel she learned her photograph was
being shown on television despite
choosing not to appear on camera in
court it was creamy
really sorry to interrupt mr. roots
cross-examination but I've just been
informed that they show you this
witness's face on the TV as we speak and
there's been a court order that that
should not be allowed and it's now
happening m'lady and I really do think
we should stop it
what's the responsible for this m'lady
I've been shown on a cell phone by our
media person they're they they they're
showing that perhaps we should just take
a German to investigate what's going yes
please
after a brief break in proceedings the
judge returned to make it absolutely
clear
she wouldn't tolerate a repeat
performance I must say this is very
disturbing I am warning the media if you
do not behave you are not going to be
treated with soft glass by this court
there was suddenly no soft gloves from
pistorius's lawyer his sole intention
keep his client out of prison by
discrediting witness Michele burgers
sequence of events I'm just giving to
the court my perception that morning and
I won't refer to a number of instances
in your evidence and I will submit to
the court I want to give you the
opportunity to respond to what you do
you have watched Sky News but other news
channels spoken to people came out in
your evidence and you have a
retrospective knowledge and you take
that knowledge and you come and give
evidence today as if it's the knowledge
of that fateful evening milady as I
stated yesterday I spoke to numerous
people that morning before finding out
of anything that it was mr. Pistorius I
spoke to my colleagues at work they can
justify what I said I even spoke to my
friend that's here today to support me I
found her at the hospital to tell her
about what I heard so I did not change
an alter what I heard Barry Roux also
took issue with how well neighbor
Michele Berger could have heard what she
did from her home
more than a hundred and seventy meters
from the scene of the shooting good year
fearing that force you could yell motion
in that voice accepting that that does
green predominantly coincide and
simultaneous with the firing of four
gunshots
you had that ability from 177 metres to
yell emotion and fear and increase
intensity in that moment plus the
gunshots and the terrible emotion I
heard the petrifying screams I heard
that moments before the gunshots that's
how I could yell emotion I did hear it
it was petrifying but we know it was a
moment moment it was so short in a
moment you can give all those emotions
the intensity the increased intensity
just petrified all in those moments yes
ma'am it's automatic it's a instinct
instinct and it's in 77 meters away in
your ass coming from another ma'am our
windows were open we had no icon and no
roof phone and our there was no vertical
building between our house at that stage
and the other house but something else
troubled Pistorius his lawyer on top of
the witnesses distance from the scene
how could we ever Steenkamp
screams be heard when she was locked
inside a toilet it's no dispute that
when the shots were fired
Riva was in the toilet we know the door
was closed we know it was locked
we know we asked the photo said the
toilet window was closed
so what you are saying to the court
hundred and seventy-seven meters away
where you only had a moment before the
shots and then shots where the person is
in a confined space you could hear
increased anxiety fear and motion in
that moment because the race moments
later without ever gunshot you heard
that out of a closed toilet and a house
177 metres away milady that's correct I
heard that man I will invite this stunt
at the time later on we don't want to
waste time to go and do a taste and I
tell you now it's a fact guys there's
some misunderstanding you can scream as
loud as you want in that toilet and
we'll put the door back for you and 177
metres you go and tell us that you can
hear that screaming but but er there was
a further rebuttal from Roo on burgers
insistence she heard reeva Steenkamp
scream after the fourth gunshot that
total impact of that shot would not
allowed to scream I want to add one
thing extra in fact the state witness
tells us Mr Man Jana with the headshot
she would have dropped down immediately
there was serious serious brain damage
and our evidence will be that the person
with that brain damage will have no
response no cognitive function no
thought process that's all coming and
that's what I put to this witness and
that will be coupled to the evidence of
the accused what he found and whether
there was any response and all the
events so all I put to this witness when
you say when you talk about the
screaming whatever interpretation after
the last bullet it cannot be on the
outcomes on the expert witnesses
it cannot be she could not have screamed
milady as I stated yesterday I heard her
voice just after the last shot faded
away pistorius's legal team also
questioned the university lecturers
statement to a police officer and it's
remarkable similarities to her husband's
did you see it on the table I can read
it I didn't read the statement yet you
see it well I didn't look for the
statement so if it was there it might
have been lying there with fibers but I
did not look for this type what's he
referring you to his type no he didn't
help it to say let me help you no he
wasn't referring to that he asked me for
my version what did I hear and you gave
then your independent version yes
independent from your I suppose correct
Michelle burgers come back perhaps
caught Barry Roux off-guard and provided
the day's light a moment window was open
that's a next crucial point yours that
we know what's open
yes sir we were in the same bedroom the
way the same thing
the laughter was short-lived as Roux
accused Michelle Berger of dishonesty
you see what I mean I could thank you to
all the other paragraphs but it's
striking TMR has been do it exactly the
same I'm afraid that is not too honest
you know what he's saying it's not their
two-year it's not new you know that so I
did not read this diary just made its
own caste and it shouldn't be made and I
will throw that there's no doubt Oscar
Pistorius is fully engaged with the
trial and his legal team here seen
passing a note forward to bury room but
there are times when being transported
back to the events of February the 14th
last year become too much for the
Olympian whatever the events of that
evening they are etched on pistorius's
mind for Michelle Berger it seems it was
the screams that night she finds
difficult to forget it was quite cool
school it was quiet emotion they're all
in motion when I'm in the shower I love
those shots you say to him that when you
in the shower during the the shots of
terrifying screams to further witnesses
were called today to give evidence about
what they heard in the early hours of
February the 14th last year Valentine's
Day the husband of Michelle Berger who
gave evidence this morning said that he
and his wife felt morally obliged to
come forward when they realized their
account of what happened that night was
different from pistorius's evidence at
his bail hearing last year another
witness
Estelle vandemeyer who lives opposite
Pistorius his home said she was woken by
loud voices in the early hours of that
morning but joined proceedings as she's
called to give evidence
my lady I woke up around 156 in the
morning
I hate sound it seems like somebody was
involved in a fight and these people are
talking in loud voices my lady and I
thought I also couldn't understand them
in what language this piece and was
talking my lady I was irritated by this
because I was supposed to go and I was
supposed to sleep seeing that my boy was
supposed to sit for exams shortly it
sounds like I placed a pillow on top of
my head we though of falling asleep once
more on our big money and around about 3
o'clock in the morning
I had four gunshots watch Emily please
explain the best you can what you have
the four sounds what was it sounded like
do you want me to describe yes the sound
if you can I see the continued move on
bang bang bang bang and she says this is
the best I can do after hearing before
four sounds he was a total silence my
lady what happened then after Rana Plaza
phone after here the portions I hit my
husband waking up I then asked him what
was doing there he then said those were
firearm sound Oh conscience within any
commotion
my husband then call the security but
short yesterday when example he was
crying out loud ok yeah it's somebody
crying I don't ask my house painters to
was crying like that he then said it was
Oscar because to me it seems like a
woman's voice my husband called the
security company lady
morning just a scream from them as to
our offseason that's when we told him
that Oscar shot his friend did you hear
any screams by in yet you know color of
his career home not at all
berry rube Pistorius his defense
advocate then cross-examine mrs.
vandemeyer he suggested that she was
mistaken in what she'd heard the fact is
you never heard any arguing but I must
say I must say that I know a woman's
voice in this abouna can define system
for our buyer by her Bobby FNS and
there's many movements you know one's
voice once Quattro especially when we
become angry across milady but here it's
far away you can't hear words you can't
your language the last witness in
today's session was the husband with
Michelle Berger who continued her
testimony earlier today charged onsen
told the court that he and his wife had
initially been reluctant to give
evidence as they thought a closer
neighbor to Pistorius would have come
forward and confirmed that both he and
his wife had been woken by a woman's
screams the night of the shooting after
the first screams I woke up I lifted my
head from the pillow to ensure that I
heard correctly and when I heard the
lady scream again I jumped out of bed
and I ran to the balcony which is on the
first floor
when I got out onto the balcony I stood
then I listened and I gained heard a
lady person screaming
I could year she was in trouble was
clearly distressed falls I can't say
exactly how long I stood it felt like a
couple of minutes and at one point I
heard a lady person scream help and
moments after that a male voice shouted
two or three times on the medic is
actually certain that it's more than
once a male person shouted help help
help it's at that point that my wife who
woke up when I got out of bed called me
back to the bedroom and said we should
phone the security we try to sleep I
laid in bed obviously concerned for for
our own security we were under the
impression that someone had been
attacked in their house in a very secure
complex and my thinking was that if it
could happen to them
the same could happen to us so I lay
awake thinking about how I can improve
our security now our house the afternoon
when I got home I got onto our roof the
roof of our house and I took a camera
with me and I was able to see the house
Oscar pistorius's house from rooftop and
I took a photograph from there
are then proceeded to go and look at the
Google Earth image and used a utility
that is available on the Google Earth
website to measure the distance it
wasn't until the bail hearing last year
that he said it became clear their
account differed from that of historias
initially we didn't want to be involved
we also assumed that if we were were so
far away 170 meters I believe I assumed
that there would be many people that are
much closer to the actual house that
would have a much clearer recollection
and we have heard more clearly what had
happened and we listened to the court
proceedings on the radio and I recall a
statement being made by the defense that
it was only one person that had
chartered or screamed that evening and
that was the accused my version differed
from that and I felt morally obliged to
come forward and provide my version
let's have a look at what's big a on in
court today and what the South African
public has made of the first two days of
what is undoubtedly a showed trial here
in this country
joining me our correspondent Alex
Crawford and Albright masago from 702
radio he's a talk show host Alex a very
emotional dramatic day in court today
yes it was for the first time we saw the
athletes demeanor crack he's been very
composed up from that I spent
a lot of time taking notes passing notes
to his lawyer occasionally turning and
talking to his family but most of the
time concentrating entirely on what's
happening legally today as we heard
details of how reeva Steenkamp died her
specific injuries the fact you know
Barry Roux outlined in quite graphic
detail there her head injuries he he
cracked he had to take out a tissue from
his top pocket and wipe his tears and
that was the first time we've really
seen that there display of emotion in
this particular proceedings and also we
had a lot of emotion from the really
strong female witness Michelle Berger
dr. Berger has been an absolute stalwart
on the stand refusing to bend under
Barry Roos very tough cross-examination
but later on when she was describing
once again having to recount the very
emotional screaming that she heard she
she lost it entirely herself and had to
spend on quite a few seconds trying to
compose herself and couldn't bring
herself together a real display of what
she herself described as bra emotion
Aubry you've been standing back a piece
away from the court but you've no doubt
have got an idea already from your
listeners on 7:02 as to what their
reactions been to what is a show trial
really in your country the very first
televised trial absolutely Jeremy it is
definitely a show trial but you remember
that one of the issues that was raised
by judge Milan ball as he made the
decision to allow media houses to
broadcast this on a 24-hour basis was
that he wanted to debunk the myth that
the South African justice system is
unfair the very fact that we are having
this particular showpiece is precisely
because we have a sporting icon which
perhaps raises the question as to
whether would this be done for other
people and I suppose that some people
would say that it is therefore unfair
but it's also raised a number of issues
for example the fact that there wasn't a
an interpreter yesterday
to stand in for the one that was
supposed to be there
raises questions about if this is
happening at this level for such a high
profile case what is happening at the
lower courts which suggests that perhaps
we are not getting the kind of justice
for the poorer people in the lower
courts as perhaps Oscar Pistorius is
having in this particular trial then of
course the whole issue of the brutality
of the advocate very root in his
cross-examination that has been quite
revealing a lot of people didn't realize
that that's the kind of thing that
happens in court and firoozeh absolutely
absolutely but of course the the the
steadfast testimony of Michelle Berger
has been something to behold so I think
that those are some of the issues that
have raised a lot of discussion amongst
the South African public and then of
course the whole issue of I think we are
beginning to understand that there
perhaps was a little bit of wisdom in
the fight by the media houses to have
this broadcast because we're now
beginning to understand what are the raw
issues that make for the for the running
of a court case of this nature which
perhaps I think a lot of people wouldn't
have known about head that's not
happening thanks very much indeed
Aubrey and Alex there for giving their
thoughts after day 2 of this fascinating
trial don't forget you can watch
continuous coverage on Sky News from
8:00 in the morning all the way through
the week and of course you can catch up
on a special program of the days offense
at 9:30 every evening on Sky News so far
South Africa's so-called trial of the
century has been compelling viewing full
of drama and raw emotion
you